the US is waging geopolitical war
against Chinese tech giant Huawei that's
according to the firm's deputy chief
he says Washington's professed
cybersecurity worries are a ruse well we
can cross live now to our T's evangelist
it's us who's in Beijing forests quite
an agreed statement man from the Chinese
site there how did he back up that claim
well it seems that the Chinese of the
Chinese come telecom Carbonell accompany
officials of actually furious and tired
of this whole antique huawei rhetoric in
a press conference in the southern the
Chinese theory of change and one of the
route 80 rotating chairman of the
company
Eric hue has been accusing Washington of
quote carrying out a coordinated
tactical geopolitical campaign against
the Chinese telecom firm the US
government is undertaking a well
coordinated geopolitical campaign
against who are we it's essentially
using a national machine against a small
company so we have been wondering is the
recent fixation on Huawei truly about
cybersecurity or could there be other
motivations but this is not the first
time that a quarries officials have been
calling out the United States just last
week they use words such as groan
grounded in senseless and how would they
were shocked and amuse of how the United
States government has been lobbying
European governments against the Chinese
firm now huge statements come after US
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo made a
tour in Eastern Europe and has been
warning its allies that if they use any
of the Chinese telecom firms equipment
and any of their major infrastructure
projects they will face consequences
when dealing with the United States
Chinese infrastructure delivered via
Huawei you mentioned Huawei in China
we've done here in Poland what we've
done all across the world the task is to
make them aware of the concerns and
risks and show them the data we've made
known the risks that are associated with
that we share with them the things we
know about the risks Huawei's presents
well it's it seems that all this
negative talk at the end it's not
actually only talk it's been paying off
French the orange carrier French which
has been using quality quite a lot
lately and it's been its top supplier of
equipment actually had now that is going
to be launching its 5g next generation
Network were we using Samsung instead
and the pressure does not stop there
just last month the US has filed
criminal
against the Chinese telecom firm Kok way
which have been accusing the company of
stealing trade secrets and has been
accusing them also of of conspiracy and
fraud and how they've been using and
trying to go around sanctions of your on
Iran now halfway has been battling
lately with a lot of this accusations
who's with the US and its Western allies
have been calling it a spy tool for the
Chinese government and of course they
became out to make a statement against
that but they're not the only ones the
Chinese state did the same it's an
absolute huge without any solid evidence
the u.s. keeps inventing crimes and
churning out different threat theories
it's using state power to suppress the
legitimate development of the rights and
interests of Chinese enterprises that is
using political means to intervene in
the economy we believe that this is
hypocritical unfair and immoral and
while there has been more and more
pressure against the Chinese telecom
firm the future of the two countries the
US and China is uncertain but I don't
not only for them for the international
trade as well
you